there's so much manipulation that
happens in school how do you prevent
your children who are in school from
being manipulated in in whatever
whatever way well I mean first of all
you have to make it comfortable to have
the tough conversations without judging
them because they'll never bring it up
to you again if you have an environment
where your kids cannot come and talk to
you openly about issues and you snap at
them that'll be the last time they'll
ever bring that issue up to you again so
you got to make sure that happens in one
time too if you break your eyes trust
like yeah I agree I I agree with you so
I think that's on the parent I think if
the parent doesn't create and like we
have a rule out the house you tell me
the truth you're not getting control
you're not getting Papa you're not
getting nothing just gotta tell the
truth so hey did you do that yeah I
punch him in the face okay cool all
right sounds good let's talk about it
why'd you do that okay hey did you
really take that idea did you open up
such and such as gift and without their
permission yes this was an issue that
happened two nights ago great so you got
to create an environment where they can
feel you have a creative trust with them
that they can talk to you about issues
right because if you don't have that
they're gonna go through it they're just
not gonna talk to